ANKUR KOTWAL: G'day, everyone.
How you guys doing?
[APPLAUSE]
ANKUR KOTWAL: That's good.
So this is the last session
before you guys
get your new toys--
I mean, Android development
devices.
That's what you're going
to use them for, right?
So we're going to make sure we
finish on time, and you guys
can rush down and
pick them up.
So the good thing is, we're
not too far from the
elevators, so you'll be
able to get down.
My name is Ankur Kotwal, and
I'm an Android developer
advocate from Sydney,
Australia.
I'm also joined today by some
friends and colleagues, Tony
Chan from Hong Kong and Tim Bray
from Vancouver, Canada.
So you'll see we have a very
global panel here today, and I
hope that you find what we're
presenting to not just be
interesting, but our aim is so
that it plants that seed in
your mind that makes you want
to build innovative and fun
experiences for your users.
So today, we're going to
talk about sensors.
And not those types of censors
that rate movies or silence
their critics.
We're talking about the pieces
of hardware in your Android
devices that provide you with
useful information that you
can't get from traditional
computing devices like laptops
or desktop computers.
So we're going to start
off by showing you a
demo that we've built.
So let's switch over.
Have we got on the
right screen?
Just waiting for it to switch.
OK, so we've built a
game of Blackjack.
And we thought, how can
we push the envelope?
Let's use four Nexus
7 devices.
With Blackjack, it's typically
dealer versus player.
You're not competing against
one another,
just against the casino.
And the aim of the game is to
have your cards tally to 21 or
as close to 21 as you can get
without exceeding it.
So let's get started.
I'm going to play the dealer,
and you'll see I've got a deck
of cards here.
And on the right-hand side,
it's the dealer's cards.
Tim and Tony have
their rounds.
So we're going to use a bunch
of gestures and a bunch of
sensors to actually simulate
this demo.
All right, so it says
game started.
What I'm going to do
is deal one card
to each of the players.
So one to Tim, one to Tony, one
to the dealer, do another
round of cards.
I'm just going to space
them out nicely.
So right now, it says
it's Tim's turn.
Tim, you're on 15.
What would you like to do?
TIM BRAY: Hit me, baby.
Wait a second.
You wrote the software,
didn't you?
ANKUR KOTWAL: I did.
So Tim said "Hit me." What that
means in Blackjack is
give me another card.
And the way you signal that in
a casino to a dealer is by
tapping on your cards
or on the table.
So Tim, could you
please do that?
One more time?
No.
There we go.
All right, so we're going
to deal a card to Tim.
And Tim, now you're on 20.
What would you like to do?
TIM BRAY: Oh, I'll stand.
ANKUR KOTWAL: You're
going to stand.
So "stand" in Blackjack
means, I'm done.
I'm happy with how many
points I'm on.
And Tim's on 20.
He doesn't want to
take a risk.
So the way you do that in a
casino is that you wave your
hand over the cards.
And you'll see that Tim's
device said you're done.
You're on 20.
It's told me to deal a card
on my side to Tony.
So Tony, what would
you like to do?
TONY CHAN: Well, I'm on 11.
I want to hit a blackjack,
so hit me.
ANKUR KOTWAL: OK,
so there we go.
It came up on mine.
Tony, you're on 18.
Come on, take a gamble.
No?
TONY CHAN: No, I'm
going to stay.
ANKUR KOTWAL: You're
going to stand.
All right so Tony
has stood on 18.
Tim is on 20.
The dealer has one card face
up, one card face down.
So we're going to
flip the card.
[LAUGHTER]
ANKUR KOTWAL: 19.
Now, that's pretty good for the
dealer, so I'm also going
to just stand.
And you'll see that that's
the end of the round.
So I was able to defeat
Tony, and I
unfortunately lost to Tim.
How about we do one more
round of that, guys?
You OK with that?
TONY CHAN: Well, I'm going
to sit this one out.
I saw your code, too.
ANKUR KOTWAL: You're saying
it's rigged, Tony?
That's fine.
So since Tony's not playing,
Tony just flipped his device.
All right, Tim, it's
just you and me.
Let's have one more round.
All right, here we go.
One card to you, one card to
dealer, one card to you, one
card to me.
What do you reckon, Tim?
Hit you, all right.
What're you on?
20.
What would you like to do?
You're standing.
All right Dealer's turn.
Blackjack!
[LAUGHTER]
TIM BRAY: He wrote the
code, like I said.
ANKUR KOTWAL: The moral of the
story is that the casino
always wins.
All right, let's switch
back to the slides.
So that was a fun little
demo that we built.
And what we want you to realize
is that that demo
didn't actually utilize the
traditional layer of
abstraction you get from
a user interface.
There were no buttons.
We were trying to build a
natural user interface to
simulate a natural experience.
And we did that using sensors.
So let's look at which sensors
and how we did it.
First and foremost, touch,
the touchscreen.
The great thing about the
touchscreen is that you
automatically get these
events passed to you.
You don't need to
ask for them.
All you have to do in your
code is override the
onTouchEvent method.
Now, on developer.android.com,
there's a lot of information
on how to process these
motion events.
And there are also third-party
websites that have a lot of
documentation for this.
So you would think, oh, well,
with all this information
available, it's really
easy, right?
Not quite.
There is a bit of a learning
curve that's involved in
processing this stuff.
So that documentation,
it helps.
So once you know what you're
doing, you can really achieve
things rapidly.
But to start off with, it can
be a little bit hard.
So what I'd like to share with
you is a couple of utility
classes that we have in the
framework that can help you.
We use the GestureDetector class
in this sample to detect
things like the tap.
And all we have to do was pass
out motion event objects to
the gesture detector, and it
would call back when one of
those gestures had
been fired off.
We also use the VelocityTracker
to track that
when I've lifted my finger after
the swipe, what speed
those cards needed
to fly across at.
So that was the VelocityTracker.
The next one is the Gesture
builder sample.
This is a piece of open-source
code that we've made available
on Google Code that allows you
to detect or capture complex
gestures, like drawing a plus
symbol and then acting on it.
Or something even more
complicated is doing a spiral.
So in a game, you might use
that to cast a spell.
So that sample there helps
you capture that gesture
and then detect it.
We also have a blog post that
goes with it, so it's really
worth your while
looking at it.
What I'd like to share with
you now is a recipe.
So we did a multi-touch gesture
to collect cards.
We used five fingers and pulled
it in, and it collected
the cards from the players.
And what we're going to do is
share an algorithm with you
with some code.
And you'll see with all of our
recipes, the way it works is
that we have a data-gathering
phase and a
gesture-detection phase.
So this here is the
data-gathering phase.
And the way it works is that
we have an initial IF
condition that says, is there
a gesture still in progress?
Because the motion event tells
us that, hey, you want to
cancel the gesture
or you want--
the last finger has come off,
so just reset your state.
That's not what we're
doing here.
We're saying we're continuing.
And what we do for
this particular
algorithm is two things.
One is get an initial snapshot
of all your fingers.
And once we have that initial
snapshot, we also go and get a
current snapshot.
And as this method is invoked
again and again, we keep
updating that current
snapshot.
Now that's the data-gathering
phase.
Let's look at the
gesture-detection phase.
What we do here is basically we
go through and compare that
initial snapshot and the
current snapshot.
So the way we do that is that we
get our initial snapshot--
well, we do this for
both snapshots.
We work out what is the maximum
distance between any
two combinations of fingers?
And we store that in our
initial snapshot.
We do the same thing for
our current snapshot.
And when the current snapshot
is 30% or less than the
initial snapshot, we consider
the gesture as having been
triggered, so initial snapshot,
current snapshot.
We can go the opposite way as
well to say when our initial
snapshot is 30% of the size
or less than our current
snapshot, we've gone
a pinch out.
So this is a very simple
implementation of that
particular gesture, but
it worked quite
well for our demo.
There is a "gotcha," and that
"gotcha" is that we have used
in our algorithm
three fingers.
We said we only need to
detect three fingers.
Now the reason for only three
fingers is because, as your
fingers converge on a
touchscreen, the touchscreen
can stop seeing them as two
skinny fingers and sometimes
start to see them as one big fat
finger when they're really
close together.
So you don't want to sit there
waiting for five fingers
because you make may never
hit your 30% threshold.
So what we do is we say,
whenever we have three fingers
or more, it's a valid
precondition for our
gesture-detection phase.
All right.
So that's the multi-finger
pinch.
One of the other interesting
things you would have seen
today is that we had this wave
gesture when we did the stand.
We just waved our hand over
the top of the device.
We didn't actually touch
the screen at all.
So you might be thinking, well,
how did we do this?
Most developers assume
that we used the
camera, and we didn't.
We've used some other sensors.
But before we talk about those,
I want to talk about
best practices when
using sensors.
See, the thing is, again,
sensors and sensor manager is
quite well documented in
a variety of places.
So what I want to share are
the best practices.
The first one is that when you
request sensor data, you can
actually specify how much or how
often it should give that
data back, the rate.
And we have four stages
or four rates
that you can specify.
You should not be tempted into
asking data back at the
fastest rate as possible.
Because if you do, you end
up like this guy--
data overload.
What do I do with it?
The sensor data doesn't
necessarily mean that you have
useful information.
It is up to you, as the
developer, to translate that.
And the way you do that is
using these different
algorithms.
But you want to make sure that
you don't have too much data,
because the more data you
have, the more effort is
required by your app to process
it, which means, then,
if you're getting too much data,
your app could be less
responsive to that gesture
because you're not processing
it in time.
The other thing you should look
at is the unregistered
part of it.
As soon as you can, you should
unregister for the sensor.
And the reason for that is
that, again, from an
efficiency point of view, your
app isn't sitting there
processing all of this sensor
data that's coming in when
you're just either not using
it or throwing it away.
The other thing that happens
from running the sensors
nonstop is that you cause
a drain on the battery.
So suddenly, your
app is now a bad
citizen on a user's device.
You never want that.
All right, now that we've talked
about this, let's go
back to those telepathic
gestures.
The first sensor I want
to talk about is
the proximity sensor.
The proximity sensor is
typically found on phones.
And what it's used for is that,
when someone's on a call
and we put the device up to our
face, the proximity sensor
turns off the screen so that
our face isn't pressing
buttons on the screen.
You don't typically find it on
tablets because people don't
tend to make phone calls on
these things, although I've
seen some really large devices
that make me feel otherwise.
Different topic.
So with a Galaxy Nexus, the
maximum range of the proximity
sensor is about 5 centimeters.
So what that means is anything
outside of 5 centimeters it
won't detect.
It'll just say there's
no obstruction.
Proximity sensors can give data
in gradual measurements--
let's say 2 centimeters
or 3 centimeters--
but many Android devices will
actually give you data in a
binary or an on/off state.
There is an obstruction
or there isn't.
So again, from a best practices
point-of-view, you
want to assume that you're
using binary data.
Now, in terms of gestures, if we
try and do a gestures where
our hand moves in and out from
the device and graph that, it
looks a little bit like this
graph here, where between 0
and 5 centimeters, I have
an obstruction.
The distance is 0 centimeters.
And above that, it's 5.
So proximity sensors
are not so useful
for detecting gestures.
What is useful is
a light sensor.
The light sensor gives you the
measurement in lumens per
square meter of your ambient
light conditions.
Now, if we look at the same
gesture with an ambient light
sensor, move our hand in and out
and graph that, what you
see is a gradual drop as the
hand comes in, and then stays
there, and then goes back out.
The cool thing about a light
sensor, however, is that we
can detect another type
of gesture, which is
the wave or the swipe.
So if we graph that, you'll see
that the drop in the graph
is a lot more sudden because
there wasn't much opportunity
where your hand was partially
covering the light sensor.
It pretty much is or it isn't.
Now, you might be looking at
that graph and saying, what's
that weird spike on the
right-hand side?
Let me explain that.
So when we recorded this
gesture, we used our fingers.
And between the four fingers and
the thumb, there is a gap.
So what's happened is when the
four fingers have swiped over
the light sensor and gone past,
light has bled through
between the fingers and the
thumb, and then the thumb has
obscured it again, which is why
you get that little drop.
So in terms of comparing these
two gestures, you have to look
at the shape of the data or
the shape of the graph.
You need to do some analysis.
What I'm going to show you now
is the recipe that we used in
the Blackjack game for the
swipe, or the stand gesture.
What we do in the data gathering
phase is literally
just fill up a circular
buffer.
Our buffer is only 100 data
points, but it's enough.
And then, every half a second,
what we do is go through that
circular buffer and work out the
maximum light reading that
we had from that buffer, and
then we get the current value
and we compare them.
If the current value is 20% or
less of that maximum value, we
consider the gesture as having
being triggered.
So initially, our maximum
value is there's lots of
light, and then suddenly,
there's a lot less light, we
consider it triggered.
This is a very simple
and unsophisticated
implementation.
But for our demo, it
was sufficient.
This particular implementation
does not distinguish between
in and out and side to side.
But as I said, it's more
than sufficient for
what we were demoing.
One last best practice that I'd
like to tell you is that I
initially talked about
the proximity sensor.
I said it's not really good
for gesture detection.
But what it is good for is
gesture validation when you're
using the light sensor.
So one of the downsides to
purely using the light sensor
is that you are relying on
consistent ambient lighting
conditions.
So if the user is using that app
on a train or bus, then as
they go through a tunnel or go
through the shadow of trees or
buildings, those light
conditions can change.
And you don't want your gesture
being incorrectly
triggered then.
So what you do is use the light
sensor to detect the
type of gesture, and then use
the proximity sensor to ensure
that there was a hand or some
sort of obstruction in front
of the device.
And then you can be certain
that it was
an intentional gesture.
Now with that, I'm going
to hand it over to Tim.
TIM BRAY: Thank you.
Hey, how about a round of
applause for that Blackjack
game that Ankur pulled
together?
[APPLAUSE]
TIM BRAY: So I'm here to talk
about motion-related stuff.
And I would normally use the
word "gesture" to describe
that, but they took that word.
Gestures is apparently now what
you do on the screen and
scribbles you make
on the screen.
So I had to think of a word.
So I'm going to say "kinetics"
to mean anything
motion-related.
And the core idea here is to
have apps that you control
without having any buttons
or sliders or any
other kind of thing.
And you can imagine lots of
different kinetic gestures you
can make with phones and devices
to control this.
We've seen some usage in
the field of shake
to undo, for example.
But I think would go a lot
further than that.
So what happened was I got an
idea for an app that would
need a lot of this stuff.
And like I always do when I'm
looking at a new Android API
that I haven't used before, I
just went out and typed it
into Google and assumed all the
best practices would pop
up on stack overflow and our own
developer pages and so on.
And I found more or
less nothing.
And that may be the real news
story of this session here
today, is not many people
are doing this stuff.
I found a few places where they
told you how to detect a
simple shake, but very, very
little for detecting anything
by way of more structured
gestures.
So the kind of stuff we're
talking about here is just not
being done that much
out there.
OK.
So when I actually sat down to
write the app, I found that
there's a lot of data coming
out of these things.
They're throwing triples of
floating-point numbers at you
many, many times per second, and
you need to get a feel for
what this data is.
And so I wrote this
app on Android
market called Sensplore.
S-E-N-S-P-L-O-R-E.
It's there.
And it gathers data.
It's the simplest possible
app you can imagine.
You press the button, and then
you shake the phone around,
doing whatever you're doing.
Then you press the button again,
and it saves it out as
a CSV file and emails
you the CSV file.
So then you drop that into a
spreadsheet, and you can look
at all the beautiful numbers
coming out of the sensor and
do things like draw graphs of
them like you see there on
that device.
Some people said, well, why
don't you just display the
values on the screen of
the device instead?
And that doesn't work.
Because, first of all,
it's too small.
And secondly, it's really hard
to watch the screen while
you're shaking the
device around.
So you can grab this and
run it and look at the
graphs and so on.
But since this is a developer
tool, you might find it
handier to download the source
from code.google.com and hack
it around to generate data
out of the sensor you're
interested in and make use of
the stuff that's already in
there for generating CSV and
emailing it to you and that
kind of stuff.
OK, it's got a few other
utility functions, too.
So there are a lot of
kinetics-related sensors on
your typical Android devices,
and they've kind of trickled
in over the years.
So typically, a modern high-end
Android device is
going to have a lot more than
an older, cheaper device.
Here is some timeline data.
It's a little bit misleading.
Just because something showed
up in API level 3 does not
mean you can assume that
it's there in every
device level 3 or higher.
Some of these correspond
directly to actual physical
sensors on the device.
Others are synthetic.
In particular, the data coming
out of the gyroscope is very
accurate and very useful.
But it doesn't come out in units
that correspond very
well to the way computer
programmers think about how
devices are moving around in
space unless, of course,
they're PhDs in math who fully
understand the appropriate
level of matrix algebra.
So anyhow, so for that reason,
there are three synthetic
sensors in there--
gravity, linear
acceleration, and rotation.
And they take the data coming
out of the accelerometer and
the gyroscope and combine it to
something that's a little
bit more programmer friendly.
The good news is that these
have gotten a lot
better since ICS.
The quality of the data that's
coming out at you really is a
lot better, but really only in
devices that have a gyroscope.
And just to make that realistic,
here's some graphs
that I drew coming out of
Sensplore of data, some
gestures I'll talk about.
But the top one is the Galaxy
Nexus and the bottom one is
the Nexus One.
And you can see-- well, first
of all, the data rate of the
samples is different on the
Nexus One, even though I put
the same argument in.
And, secondly, the data on the
Nexus One is much less
granular and much messier
and sort of floppy and
harder to deal with.
It may be the case that for
certain apps, you might want
to probe for the presence of the
gyroscope and decline to
proceed without it.
OK, so let's talk about some
of the data coming out.
You have to learn to think in
terms of coordinate systems.
The sensors typically, for the
motion stuff, give you triples
of floating point data.
And it's really totally
essentially that you go and
read the Java Docs in detail,
which are all in the Sensor
Event Java Docs because
sometimes they are moving
along the axes, and
sometimes they're
moving around the axes.
And by the way, since we're
all from Commonwealth
countries, those would be
the x-, y- and z axes.
In device coordinates, x is
right, y is up, and z is
towards you.
So another reason you have to
read the Java Docs is they
don't always come out
as x, y, and z.
Some of them come out as z, x,
and y, and there's no way to
find out that without
reading it.
That corresponds to yaw, pitch,
and roll, for those of
you who are aeronautical
engineers.
Now, as far as I know, all of
the data coming out of the
devices is in device
coordinates, not world
coordinates, where y is North, x
is East, and z is coming out
of the center of the Earth.
And that's OK for
a lot of stuff.
But if you want to do something
like a compass, you
really need to transform things
into world coordinates.
Now, you can do that because
we've got a magnetic field
censor and a gravity
sensor and so on.
But it requires some really
fairly advanced 3D rotation
matrix math that I once
knew, but then I
forgot 15 minutes later.
Quaternions and things
like that.
Fortunately, there's a lot
of helper functions.
One particular thing you've got
to watch out for is that
the device coordinate
system is up towards
the top of the device.
And when you turn it sideways
in the landscape mode, well,
it now has a different
top, and all
your data values change.
You can actually see the readout
change as it gets past
45 degrees.
And enough people have been
screwed up by this that we
actually wrote a whole great big
long blog post about how
to avoid getting screwed up by
sensor rotation, because
there's lots of ways you can try
and fix it that don't work
and one that does.
So you should go
and read this.
There's a bunch of other
things to worry about.
And probably the primary thing
is the one Ankur already
mentioned because doing this
kind of programming is a
really good way to burn the
battery on your device.
And it's not so much that the
little, tiny, infinitesimal
bit of silicon in there
is burning power.
It's that it calls back into
your code 10, 20, 50 or more
times a second.
And this isn't a simple kind
of callback where you
increment an integer.
You're typically passing on
a bunch of floating point
numbers and diving straight into
the trigonometry library
or doing matrix inversions
and multiplications
and things like this.
And you're typically doing it,
not on lightweight local
variables, but on class
variables that are full of
shared state, because they're
getting called back.
So this is not lightweight
computing, and you don't have
to be a rocket scientist to
figure out that it's going to
play hell with your battery.
So what that means is only
sample as fast as you need to.
And especially, you've got to
stop sampling when you don't
need to anymore.
So when your app gets an
on-pause event or you're
passing something you've
recognized off the client
code, you've got to turn
off the sensors.
Because the system won't, and
you'll sit there in the
background with the sensors
grinding and the
battery going like this.
So don't do this.
Another thing to watch out for,
as you saw on that graph,
is the sampling rate.
It changes from device to
device, so you actually have
to look at and use the time
stamp comes in with the sensor
event, which is irritatingly
in nanoseconds, not
milliseconds, and irritatingly
not synchronized with the
system time.
Oh well.
What else do you have
to worry about?
Oh, well, just the fact that
the data is messy.
These are not high-grade
industrial A-to-D converters
that they'll use in steel
mills and so on.
These are flimsy little bits
of the silicon that are put
into handsets by cost-conscious
manufactures.
And the data is janky and messy
and has variation in
static, and you just have
to deal with that fact.
And one particular thing
to watch out for is the
accelerometer.
Now, the accelerometer
is a cool device.
There's this video you can see
on YouTube as to how it's
actually built.
There actually is a little
prong of silicon with the
stuff underneath it etched
away that is on
a little thin stem.
And it actually bends and
changes, causes variations in
the current.
And there's three of
these things facing
in the three axes.
And they measure the attractive
forces, which
obviously include gravity.
And that means that the only
time the accelerometer is
giving you a zero readout is
when the device is falling or
it's in orbit.
One side effect of this is that
if you take an Android
device into orbit, all the games
will immediately stop
working because they count
on gravity being there.
So, I said that Ankur
wrote all of the
code for the Blackjack.
Well, there was one piece I
wrote, which was the thing
where he flipped it up and
the cards flipped over.
So let's talk through that in
detail and get a feel for how
this kind of stuff works.
So this graph here shows what
happens when I take a Galaxy
Nexus and I hold it facing me
and I chop left, back, right,
and forward, simple discrete
chop motions.
So what we're interested in here
is obviously the last of
those four motions,
chop forward.
And so the top graph shows
the actual raw
accelerometer data readout.
The bottom graph shows a readout
of the change in angle
around the x-, y- and
z-coordinates per sample.
I'll show you how you
get that in a sec.
And it's easy to see by looking
at this, that the
motion we're looking for is
characterized by a sustained
and fairly large delta angle
around the x-coordinate in a
negative direction because it's
coming up toward you as
opposed to going down.
So that's the condition we're
going to look for.
So let's look at some
of the code here.
So once again, this is the best
practice design pattern
you see in sensor-reading
code.
You always check the type of the
sensor that you're getting
the event for, and that allows
you to pack all your different
sensor handling code into one
class, too, with a K-statement
wrapped around it.
So in this case, I'm going to
handle the rotation vector
sensor, which is a synthetic
sensor, again.
And here's where we're going
to do all the math.
So we get these float arrays,
which are three by three, and
the central operation here
compares two of them, these
two rotation matrices to compute
a change in angles.
And you don't have to be a
genius to figure out that it's
probably a bad idea to allocate
three-by-three
floating point matrices
50 times a second.
That's going to make
your garbage
collector super unhappy.
So that flipper class there
simply keeps two of them
around and flips them back
and forth, so you
have next and last.
So what happens is we
get called with a
vector of three arguments.
And we call the library routine
there to turn them
into a matrix, and then we
compare it to last matrix and
that gives us the delta and
angles and radians per--
I have no idea what the
units are, radians per
something or other--
around the z-, x-, and y-axes.
And then so we'd go and
do some comparison.
And because to deal with all
the static we've got some
threshold values, and we
established two Booleans,
minus x and plus x, depending
on whether we've decided the
device is rotating forwards or
backwards around the x-axis.
So then a dive into the code.
So all the sensor code I've
written ends up being a sort
of a twisted-state machine.
I don't know, maybe some
other technique will
work better for you.
I say "twisted" because I
require that the device stay
in a particular state for a
certain amount of time.
In particular, you chop the
device, then it settles down.
So there's this state called
being at rest, and I require
that it stay there for a certain
number of clicks
before I'll start looking
for a new state.
So this is pretty easy to see.
So I sum up clicks for awhile,
and then I start looking.
And if it goes negative, I move
into the Going Negative
state, and then it goes
positive, I move into the
Going Positive state.
And then, if I'm in the Going
Negative state, which is
flipping up, and I require
that it stay there for a
certain amount of time, and then
I detect the case that
it's no longer in that state,
and I decide that we've
detected a flip-up event and
dispatch to Ankur's code to
turn the cards over.
You'll notice that when I do
that dispatch, the first thing
I do is instantly unregister all
my listeners so that the
sensors are no longer running
And then I call his code.
And if it returns true,
I turn them back on.
Otherwise, I don't.
So that's what it's like
down against the
cold face of the sensors.
Tony, you want to show
that tilt up there?
TONY CHAN: Sure.
TIM BRAY: So here's a silly
little app I wrote to see if
this works.
It's got to be vertical.
Oh, well, maybe this isn't going
to-- oh, there is it.
OK, it shows this thing
on the screen.
And as Tony tilts back and
forth, it keeps it level.
It keeps the red line
level as the device
moves back and forth.
Trust me, it looks cool.
It's in the Sensplore app,
the code for it.
Anyhow, so what we're trying
to do is simply calculate--
let's go back to the slides,
which is one?
TONY CHAN: Two.
TIM BRAY: Two.
Hello?
Slides?
Yeah, so we're going to try to
calculate that angle theta to
figure out how far we slipped.
And a little bit of trigonometry
suffices.
But there's some other
interesting stuff in here.
So first of all, you have
to be defensive.
You're computing the ratio
between the value of gravity
and the component of that along
the vertical axis of the
phone and taking the
arc cosine of that.
And if you feed a number greater
than 1 to math.acos,
it gets all unhappy
and barfs at you.
So you have to defend yourself
against that.
The other thing you have to
watch out for is that the
units coming out of the sensors
may be non-intuitive,
so there's a certain amount of
adding and subtracting pi/2.
And then the real problem I
fought within in this thing is
as the math routines get near
the zero and come out the
other side, they go nonlinear
sometimes, and you get weird
variations.
So you need a circular buffer
in there that saves up some
small number of samples.
I think I used five.
And so each time you get a new
data point, you put in there.
It takes out the oldest one and
returns you the average of
all the ones that
are in there.
So that smooths out the
curve a little bit.
So this is the kind
of defensive
programming you have to do.
Now, one thing you'll notice is
a lot of Android games, you
hold the device flat like this,
and you tilt it back and
forth, and your spacecraft goes
right or left, or the
ball rolls around, or
something like that.
The reason game developers
love to do this, and the
reason I recommend it, is you
can use the accelerometer data
almost directly.
If you're holding it flat like
this, if you think about it,
the component of gravity
is zero, both on this
axis and that axis.
And as you tilt it a little bit
this way, it goes positive
on this axis and negative,
positive, negative.
And it turns out you can use the
values coming out of this
almost directly, if you think
about the math, as force
values, which gives you
acceleration values.
And if you remember Newton's
laws of motion, you can
integrate and compute where the
spacecraft is, or where
the little ball rolled
to, or so on.
There's a nice mathematical
technique called Verlet
integration.
And there's this terrific sample
in the samples with the
SDK that uses Verlet integration
to track a bunch
of little silver balls rolling
around on a surface with an
astoundingly small
amount of code.
Very elegant, very, very good.
OK, so I advise you to get it.
Now, if you're like me, you saw
what these sensors could
do, and you immediately thought,
wow, I can track
motion in space.
I'm going to build
a light saber and
track balletic motions.
And, well, no, you
can't, sorry.
Well, anyhow, I couldn't.
And I tried really hard
for a couple of weeks.
It turns out that this is not
like a Nintendo Wii, which has
multiple high-quality industrial
gyroscopes in it.
Phones have these much smaller,
much less precise
objects, and the data coming out
is nowhere near accurate
enough to track your
position in space.
And I would point out that the
Microsoft Kinect actually uses
a camera sitting in there to
track where the thing is
moving and gets really, really
accurate data like that.
Now, there are some
things you can do.
You can very easily compute the
total acceleration of the
device, which is very,
very useful in
tracking things like shakes.
And you can get general events,
such as they jerked it
left, they jerked it right, they
jerked it up, they jerked
it down, this kind of thing.
I found that, generally
speaking, rotational events of
one sort or another were
easier to capture.
But it's tough stuff.
The last thing I'm going
to talk about is
how to build a compass.
There are several examples
of compasses out
there on the net.
This is actually Ankur's
code here.
The complicated thing is moving
from device coordinates
to world coordinates.
And to do this, first of all,
you have to get both the
accelerometer and the magnetic
field data, and then you have
to do some very, very scary
real math to change the
coordinates.
And, well, here's an example
of that math in action.
And it's actually not that hard
to construct something
that keeps the needle pointing
magnetic north, anyhow.
If you want true North, you'd
have to do GPS math and all
sorts of stuff.
Let me backtrack.
Probably the best example of
sensor programming I've ever
seen on an Android is something
that just came out
now with Jelly Bean.
And this is what's called the
Compass View in the Maps app,
so you get the Maps app,
particularly on a device like
the Nexus 7 here.
And you go to a location, and
you go into Street View, then
hit the Menu and select
Compass mode.
And it is remarkable.
You hold it like this, and it
captures the most subtle,
slightest variations in the way
you hold the device and
moves-- pans around the view
you're looking at.
It is totally magical.
Now, that is accomplished using
techniques that are
probably a bit more advanced
than the ones I
talked about here.
They involve taking the actual
rotation matrices and using
quaternions and probably taking
them and blasting them
straight into the OpenGL
code that is
actually driving the maps.
The bad news is that you really
have to be a competent
mathematician who really
understands this stuff in
order to use that stuff.
But if you really want to
achieve that kind of
semi-magical effect, you're
going to have to do it.
The good news, however, is that
the library routines have
been set up carefully so that
the rotation matrices that
come out are either
nine-by-nine, or
three-by-three, or
four-by-four.
And they are set up in such a
way that they can be pumped
directly into the OpenGL
routines that want rotation
matrices, and they're all
just right, just the
way you want them.
And so it's not that hard to
write, assuming you know what
you're doing.
OK, I think that's all
I'm going to--
you all know what you're
doing, right?
That's all going to say about
motion and kinetics.
You know, as Ankur showed, your
device can feel and see
what's going on around it.
And as I've been showing
you, it can feel what
you do to it as well.
Now, it can do one more thing,
which is listen.
So, Tony, take it away, give
us audio processing.
TONY CHAN: Thank you, Tim.
So besides being able to
detect your motion with
Android, Android can also listen
to you through the
microphone.
But if I ask you, as a developer
usually how you use
the microphone, you probably
will say use it for voice
recording or music
recording, right?
But what if I tell you you can
use the microphone to make it
as a baby monitor?
Or a musical instrument tuner?
Or even use it to detect some
inaudible frequency that only
your application
can understand.
So a good use case of that is
maybe in global positioning.
So there are a lot of
interesting ways you can use
the microphone.
And today, I want to show you
another interesting way of
using the microphone as
a heartbeat monitor.
So here, let me walk you
through what I built.
So here I have a regular
stethoscope that is used by
any doctor around the world.
And I connect one side of the
earpiece of the stethoscope to
an external microphone, which
is connected by a very
sophisticated piece
of connector--
actually, I'm kidding.
This is a pencil grip.
I got it online.
But it would fit perfectly
the two ends.
So the other end of that the
microphone is connected to the
headphone jack of the
Android device.
So let me--
So I cannot talk while taking
the measurements, so I'll ask
Ankur to help me to take
the measurement.
So I want to walk you
through what the
application is working--
ANKUR KOTWAL: It's
dangerously high.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
TONY CHAN: Wow.
It picked up your clapping,
so let it settle
down a little bit.
So this is how the heartbeat
monitor is working.
So first, it takes the heartbeat
sound signal from
the stethoscope.
This is still analog,
by the way.
And then the signal goes to the
microphone, and then we do
some sampling.
And after that, I pass it
through a low-pass filter.
And then before displaying the
signal on the screen, I do a
down-sampling.
So we will talk a little bit
about all these steps in the
future slides.
So I guess--
TIM BRAY: I'll go back.
Back to the slides?
TONY CHAN: You're still
pretty excited
actually, Ankur, today.
ANKUR KOTWAL: I get to share a
stage with you guys, so I'm
pretty excited, right?
TONY CHAN: Yep.
So let's talk about how you can
access the microphone in
the Android framework.
So if you are just talking about
recording some sound or
music and code it in some
common format, the
MediaRecorder class is what
you're looking for.
However, if you need to do
some advanced signal
processing stuff, you need
to access the raw data.
You need to use the
AudioRecord class.
And by the way, the MediaRecord
class is available
since day one of Android, and
the AudioRecord classes is
available since 1.5.
So before we get to the more
technical part of the session,
let's start with some
fundamentals so that we are
the same page.
The human hearing range is
between 20 Hz and 20 kHz.
And this range will shrink
when we get older.
Well, I guess actually that's
a pretty nice thing, because
suddenly all our mp3 songs
will sound like CD song
quality when we get older,
because we cannot tell the
difference anymore.
When we talk about sound
wave, there are two
things we talk about--
The pitch and the loudness.
So pitch is really the frequency
of the sound, and
loudness is the amplitude,
as illustrated
in the diagram here.
One interesting property thing
about sound waves is it
respects something called
superposition principle.
And this allows us to analyze
a very complex signal in its
simpler, fundamental sinusoidal
components.
And this is what enabled us to
do what we call the SWIFT,
Fourier transform, which is the
low-pass filtering stuff.
So now, let's--
sorry, I'll skip a slide,
but that's the idea.
The next thing I want to talk
about is sampling So Tim
actually mentioned about
sampling before, but this is
really important, and I think
a lot of developers didn't
quite get how to choose the
right sampling rate.
So I want to point out one thing
about sampling rate.
The sampling rate, 44.1 kHz,
is the only sampling range
that is guaranteed
to support in all
Android-compatible devices.
However, does that mean that
this is the frequency you
should use as a default
frequency when you do sampling?
Well, guess what?
The answer is no.
And the reason is you should
always understand very well
about your signal before you
choose the right frequency.
So you may ask the question,
now, how can I choose the
right frequency?
It turns out the good
news is there is
really a rule of thumb.
You always want to pick a
sampling rate that is more
than two times the
highest frequency
component of your signal.
And if you ask why, well,
trust me on that one.
Actually, there are some smart
people already proved that in
mathematics.
So if this condition is not
satisfied, something called
aliasing will occur.
And I want to show you visually
what that means.
So here, I have a signal
of 0.9-Hertz frequency.
And I'm going to sample this
signal at 1 Hertz.
So you can see there are a lot
of blue dots on the screen,
which is the sample data.
So it looks OK, until now I
introduce another signal of
0.1 Hertz, which I call
the alias signal.
So as you can see from the
graph, this alias signal fits
perfectly on all the sample
data you have.
And this is the problem.
Because there's no way you can
reconstruct an original signal
reliably if you sample
your data at 1 Hertz.
So now, how to solve
this problem?
So let's say I am now, instead
of 1 Hertz, I'm going to
sample this data at 2 Hertz,
which is more than two times
the original signal frequency.
So now, there are more
data points that
we're capturing now.
So we take a sample every half
a second, and so you can see
the alias signal no longer fits
the new sample data, and
this is how we solve
the problem.
So another topic I wanted to
talk about is how to choose
the right buffer size.
So it turns out there's no
one-size-fits-all solution to
that, because it's really a
trade-off among a couple of
things, like responsiveness
and memory, CPU
cycle, things like that.
So if you choose a small buffer,
so you can update your
UI more frequently.
So that's a nice thing.
But if you choose a large
buffer, you probably put more
stress to your system, use more
memory and CPU cycle for
each round of operation.
However, there is really a
plus on picking a larger
buffer, which is your
application will be more
tolerant to failure by network
congestions or resource
competition with other
applications
in the Android system.
There are also a couple of
pitfalls I want to point out.
So the first one is always make
sure you call the Gadmin
buffer side method to initialize
your AudioRecord
class, because this is the
minimum buffer requirement to
properly instantiate the
AudioRecord object.
Another thing is this is also
the size of a buffer that will
guarantee you not dropping
sample data.
Another thing is when you pick
the encoding bit def, make
sure you use the right method.
So if you are using the
8-bit encoding, use
the read(byte) method.
And if you're using the 16-bit
one, make sure you use the
read(short) method.
Trust me, that will save you
from a lot of trouble.
So now let's get to
signal processing.
So when do you usually
do signal processing?
So there are a couple
of things.
So the first one is if you want
to filter some noises.
And I would like to show you a
quick demo, like what we can
achieve by adding a filter
to a signal.
So let's turn the filter
off right now.
So you can see a very strong
signal right here.
And if I turn on the filter, you
can see immediately, the
signal goes away, besides
my voice.
So that quickly illustrates how
a low-pass filter works.
Another use case for doing
signal processing is if you
want to do some spectral
analysis on your signal.
But one thing about doing this
kind of signal processing is
it's really, really hard to
do it in the time domain.
So I have to diagram here that
the same signal, but in
different formats, one in time
domain and one in the
frequency domain.
So, as you can see, in the
time domain, there isn't
really much things
you can do to
de-componentize your single.
But on the other hand, in the
frequency domain, you can find
it very easy to see individual
components that
represent your signal.
So that's why a lot of people
are doing all this low-pass
filtering in the frequency
domain.
Now, the question is, how can
you transform your signal from
the time domain to the
frequency domain?
And I have another good
news for you.
So someone already
figured this out.
So it's what we call the
Discrete Fourier Transform.
And this is math.
So when we talk about
DFT, it's really a
computing-intensive operation.
So the complexity of DFT
is really N squared.
However, in practice, thanks to
some computer scientists,
we already figured out another
more efficient algorithm to
achieve the same result, which
is, Fast Fourier Transform,
FFT And the complexity
of that is N log N.
But even that, when you
implement FFT, you can choose
to use some library.
But it's not really
a lot of code.
But if you really implement
FFT, there are a couple of
things you want to
look out for.
The first thing is, of course,
garbage collection.
So, I saw some implementation of
FFT using a Java object to
represent a complex
data value.
That's really expensive, because
if you are talking
about sampling data at 44.1
kilohertz, you are talking
about creating 40,000 objects
for every single second, which
is totally inefficient.
So in my demo, instead of
using a Java object to
represent a complex data value,
I'm using two arrays of
double primitive to store the
complex data value, so one for
the real part of the number
and another part for the
imaginary one.
Another thing, when you write
your methods, consider doing
something called in-place
algorithm, if possible.
If your algorithm can do that,
do it, because you can save a
lot of memory.
So basically, what that does is
we use the input array to
store the output of
your results.
And finally, if your computation
is really complex,
you can always consider
using the NDK.
So now, it's relatively
easy to get
sensor data from Android.
However, it is quite challenging
to really make
sense of the data, as teammate
Ankur pointed out earlier.
So I would like to share some
tips with you on how to really
understand or interpret data.
So the first one is
using thresholds.
In Tim and Ankur's code snippet
earlier, we're using a
lot of places using thresholding
to extract useful
information from the
sensor data.
And in my heartbeat
demo, I also used
that in a couple places.
The first one is I used that
to detect peaks, heartbeat
peaks, in order to calculate
the heartbeat rate.
Another place I used that is I
used that to filter out some
peaks that are too close
to each other.
And the third place I used this
is because I don't want
the heartbeat rate to fluctuate
too quickly.
So I used some threshold
criteria to determine--
only if the heartbeat rate
repeat like x number of times,
then I update the UI.
So threshold is really
useful when you're
handling sensor data.
Another thing is time.
In my heartbeat demo, I'm using
time combining with the
sensor data to calculate
the heartbeat rate.
Finally, statistics are your
friend when you handle sensor
data because sensor data are
inherently noisy, messy, as
Tim mentioned.
It's always good to use some
basic statistics to interpret
and understand your data.
And in my heartbeat demo, I used
something called weighted
moving average to control how
sensitive the heartbeat
detection algorithm.
So it turns out it works
pretty well.
So after you get all the data,
you want to display them to
your user, right?
So the Android framework comes
with a visualizer in the
AudioEffects package.
However, there are
a couple caveats.
So the first thing is, in order
to use this visualizer,
the visualizer only applies to a
current playing audio track.
In other words, in my example,
since I'm not playing the
heartbeat sound, so I cannot use
the visualizer that comes
with the Android framework, so
I have to build my own custom
visualizer.
But when you have to build a
custom visualizer, there are a
couple of things you
need to remember.
First of all, you have to
down-sample your data, because
on any phone screen,
you probably only
1,280 pixels, right?
But you definitely have
a lot more data
points when you do sampling.
So make sure you have to
down-sample your data.
And probably it's a good idea
to pass your data through a
low-pass filter before doing
the down-sample.
If you want to achieve that
horizontal scrolling effect on
the UI I have, you also want
to use a circular buffer to
keep track of your data.
So that's pretty much what I
want to talk about audio.
And I hope you guys find it
useful, and I really look
forward to see some more
exciting ways of using the
microphone in your applications
in Google Play.
So I'll pass this stage
back to Tim.
TIM BRAY: All right.
[APPLAUSE]
TIM BRAY: Thank you, Tony.
So check that link there.
That's where our organization,
the Developer Relations
Organization, puts our
training materials.
As of yet, there's not
actually a course on
sensors there yet.
But there will be real soon now
as a consequence of having
done this session.
And it's a super valuable
resource for anybody who's
trying to be an Android
developer.
So a housekeeping note
and a takeaway.
Housekeeping note is we're kind
of low on time already,
so I don't think we're going to
really be able to do much
in the way of questions here.
We're all going to go from
here straight up to the
Android Office Hours
on the third floor.
And you want to talk about
sensors or anything else, come
on up and find us there, and
we can relax and talk.
Final point I want to make is
it's hard to stand out.
There's a lot of apps up
there in Google Play.
Not many people are doing
the sensor stuff.
This could be the hook that
makes your app stand out from
the big, big, big crowd.
Thank you.